Hey, I got a funny voicemail at two one nine
two David P. about my pronunciation of a city
in Oklahoma.
Take a listen.
Hey, thank you for listening to this.
I'm a listener and I love your show.
I just want to let you know that I watched
the episode where Trump was at Mount Rushmore
and said lots of things incorrectly.
And when you announced that he was at Tulsa,
Oklahoma, you said Tulsa.
So you might want to go back and correct that.
Yeah.
So nobody catches it and says anything bad
about you.
Absolutely.
Delightful voicemail.
People will say bad things about me.
Either way, it's just an inside joke.
Going back to the Tulsi Gabbard.
Tulsi days.
I'm just mispronouncing it in the same.
It's just it's a dumb inside joke.
And I apologize if anybody was upset by it.
But, you know, I know that it's pronounced
Tulsa, Oklahoma.
But just to get us back to the days of the
Democratic primary, I've been having a good
time calling it Tulsa.
But I know that it's Tulsa.
I appreciate it anyway.
OK.
Next Tuesday, David Pakman Show Chess Tournament,
8:00 p.m. Eastern.
Sign up for free today at David Pakman dot
com slash chess.
And next Tuesday, one day membership special
to try to recover some of the 300 lost memberships
of the last week.
Get notified about both the chess tournament
and the membership special by getting on our
newsletter at David Pakman dot com.
I'll see you on the bonus show, which are
existing members, of course, already have
access to.